nous nous préparons et nous anticipons
l'arrivée d'un vaccin
l'anticipation maître mot du
gouvernement 90 millions de doses
auraient déjà été réservés elle devrait
être livrée pour la nouvelle année votée
dans le budget 2021 de la sécurité
sociale un milliard et demi d'euros sera
entre autres consacré à cet achat mais
avant cela la france doit attendre
l'aval de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
on se met dans les starting blocks pour
distribuer un vaccin dès lors que
celui-ci aura bénéficié des
autorisations et des validations par les
autorités scientifiques nationales et
internationales
l' agence européenne du médicament a dit
qu'elle pensait pouvoir donner une
validation à un premier vaccin la fin de
l'année pour qu'ils puissent être
distribués à partir du mois de janvier
après l'autorisation de l'agencé
européenne du médicament la france devra
aussi obtenir l'aval de la commission
européenne
car c'est à bruxelles que sera évaluée
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
la commission se base sur l'évaluation
scientifique réalisée par l' agence
européenne du médicament avant que la
procédure n'arrive à son terme
reste donc à la france la possibilité de
se préparer à l'arrivée d'un vaccin est
selon le ministre de la santé
le chantier est monumentale nous avons
d'ores et déjà acheté par exemple par
exemple que je vous donne 50 super
congélateur qui permettent de stocker à
moins 80 degrés des produits de santé
qui sont reliés à des alarmes qui seront
entreposés dans des temps dans des
endroits sécurisés à partir desquels des
équipes vont se déployer pour ensuite
alimenter tous ceux qui seront amenés à
vacciner etc
c'est un chantier qui monumentale de
cherté de la vaccination
le vaccin concernés et pour l'instant
celui de father et bio ntech alliance
ponctuelle d'un géant américain et d'une
société de biotechnologie allemande dans
d'autres pays le remède fait son entrée
plus rapidement aux etats unis 20
millions de personnes pourraient être
vaccinés avant la fin de l'année la
société américaine moderna devrait voir
la commercialisation de son vaccin
autorisé dès le début du mois de
décembre en chine environ un million de
personnes ont reçu une dose d'un vaccin
expérimental produit par sinopharm group
pharmaceutique d'état sur le continent
africain le maroc
a également choisi le vaccin chinois
ainsi qu'un vaccin britannique le
royaume devrait immunisés sa population
dès le mois prochain